[Music]
what up guys goes in here and boy do we
have a lot to talk about after this
episode man I called it I said last week
it would be insane and it even surpassed
my expectations what an amazing action
feels information-packed episode it was
into boot as a perfect cherry on top of
this amazing finale we got news and we
already posted a video earlier today
that season 3 will be dropping in 2018
so next year guys all the people who
were saying that we would have to wait
another four years or longer we're wrong
thank god this is amazing news and if
you're all so psyched smash that like
button and let's get to this episode
review if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe we have plenty of
attack on time videos on this channel
and many more on the way so stay tuned
so we start on the cliffhanger we ended
up on last episode we have Eren and
Mikasa sitting there while the smiling
Titan is approaching the same Titan who
killed Aaron's mother by the way if you
want to know everything there is to know
about the smiling Titan make sure to
check out my smiling tiny explained
video video link in the description so
Hannes shows up and wants to repay his
debt to the Yeager family
it was Aaron's father who helped steer
his family when a contagious disease hit
the village many years ago Hannes also
wants to erase the shame he feels for
abandoning Aaron's mother because he was
so shaken last time and ran with the
kids leaving the mother to be devoured
Hannes is a great character in my
opinion and you can tell how close he is
with all three of the children because
Aaron and Armin he is like a parent
figure to them all and someone who is
proud of them and reminds them of the
old times when they were kids and their
parents were still alive except
tragically Mika sons who were already
killed by humans at that point and I
think you'll notice especially in this
episode they're emphasizing that
humanity itself is the real enemy other
humans not so much these evil Titans
while Hannes is fighting we have Aaron
trying to bite his hand and turn into a
Titan but it won't work and it's shown
that his fingers have
fully grown back from when he was ripped
out of his Titan by bed salt and Reiner
it's very hard to watch I gotta say they
did a great job of animating this scene
you can feel his pain and desperation
Aaron says that nothing has changed and
that he is just as helpless as he was
back then in a way it does seem like
it's true he always used to have me
curse of protecting him and his mother
told him that he should learn to protect
Mikasa for a change but here it doesn't
seem like he's going to be able to do it
without his Titan powers that he usually
relies on so he becomes a crying mess
Hannes puts up a great attempt to kill
the smiling Titan but it's tragically
killed in a scene that is very
reminiscent of the scene that we saw
back then when Aaron's mother was eaten
it seems like history is repeating
itself here before me Kassadin Aaron's
eyes you gotta admit it does seem like
almost any character can die in this
anime I mean we even thought our main
character dodges in a few episode
anyways the end of Hannes is hard for
our main characters to take obviously
not only is Hannes like a parent figure
to them he does remind them of and
represent the old times before Reiner
and Berthold broke down the walls and
forever changed the course of their
lives I've gotta admit this is
definitely one of the saddest that's so
far because we've been given so much
time to get to know Hannes and care for
him we even get flashbacks of when he
was playing with the three of them when
they were all still kids
I gotta admit guys this death got to me
in the manga and again in the anime so
much feels we go back to err and crying
and feeling worthless and you can see
the pain in Mika some space and it's so
hard for her to see Aaron like this we
probably all know that she loves him
already but in this episode it seems
like she finally gets this information
clearly through to Aaron she thanks him
for giving her life purpose and for
giving her his scarf and for wrapping
around her which was practically the
lifeline she needed to save her from the
cold darkness she was in after her
parents were killed Aaron then realizes
that he has to stop crying and step up
in an amazing and feels gushing moment
he tells me cuz so that he'll wrap the
scarf around her as many times as she
wants at this point the smiling time
reaches out to him he regenerates the
rest of his finger
forms of fist it screams out as he
punches the smiling Titan all of a
sudden butter told Reiner and Amir the
other Titan shifters around feel a spark
in their minds not going to lie it looks
a lot like their spidey sense went off
so you know something's going to go down
all of a sudden the surrounding forward
Titans attack the smiling Titan
devouring it and I gotta say it's gory
and hard to watch as her flesh gets
ripped apart but it's not like it's
human or anything so it's fine right
except one of the last scenes shows us
that these Titans most likely were all
humans just like Connie his mother was
turned into a human because of this fact
and the fact that the smiling Titan was
a human - most likely it seems like they
purposely made a diss gory and hard to
watch to make us all of a sudden realize
maybe she wasn't evil maybe she was like
Connie's mother a good person who became
a mindless Titan what Emir described as
living in a nightmare and having no
control of your actions and now we see
this perhaps good innocent human who was
acting against her will be brutally
killed and eaten alive by other Titans
the fact is the Titans do feel pain so
this revenge that Eren God is at least
in my opinion not as satisfying as he
probably thought it would be indiana's
because I was holding him which is a
very cutesy and by the way he's not
thinking about how amazing it is that he
finally killed the tightening got
revenge he is thinking about the people
he's lost and how killing this Titan
didn't and can never bring them back it
was also interesting how Arman doesn't
really seem to be attacked by Titans in
the first few episodes of attack on
Titan it was commented on how the Titans
to not go after Arman and here again the
Titan was following Jean but then
stopped when Arman was trying to protect
him we see other times moving albeit in
slow motion but this Titan is just
staring and not really getting any
closer I do think that this is
noteworthy and will come into play later
on so watch out for that let me know if
you do remember a time when Arman was
actually attacked by a mindless Titan
below and if you do let me know the
specific episode or manga chapter aside
from that however we see now that Eren
can clearly control the Titans not only
does he send
all to eat the smiling Titan afterwards
when Reiner starts chasing him he sends
them to attack rider and bertolt he does
this through kinds of screams which is
why the episode is called scream Reiner
and Berthold though don't refer to it as
a scream they're referring to air and
having the coordinate and that he's the
worst person who can have it now if you
want to know everything there is to know
about this power that Aaron used to
control the Titans be sure to check out
Mike worden explained video the point is
now the Titans are going to kill Rider
and vessels who seems to be exhausted in
the same boat as Aaron and can't
transform then to everyone's surprise
Ahmir in her Titan form apologized to
historian and goes back to help them
fight off the Titans I mean this is
insane Ahmir and historian really got
some screen time in this episode they
shared how much they cared about each
other and historian said that they
should live for no one else but
themselves and even that she feels like
she can do anything when a mirrors by
her side Amina was trying to save her by
bringing her to wherever Reiner and
Bethel's were going but she didn't end
up doing it she said there was no future
in the walls but she changed her mind
after she saw Aaron using his new power
that allowed him to control the Titans
so this power that Aaron has does seem
to give a mere hope that the walls can
be saved yet she went to help Rider and
vessels why a mere let me know why you
think she did it I told you guys how
selfless Amir is and this really proves
it she trades her dream life with a
story away so that she could save these
other two Titan shifters because she
knows their situation and understands
that they'll be in trouble if they go
back to wherever they're going
empty-handed
the rider even who tries to let her go
but she wants to repay them because if
they didn't come to break down the walls
she never would have experienced her new
life and she would have never met
historian 2 Amir would have continued
experiencing her endless nightmare as a
mindless Titan then she says it is not
bad playing the goddess suggesting that
she feels good doing something selfless
even though I'm sure a lot of us would
have wanted her to go back to the wall
even if she rescued rider and vegetables
first let me know what you guys think of
her decision
she wants to give back the power she
took but is it really necessary we also
get a scene of Levi's which is very
interesting we usually don't see Levi
affected usually she tries to be as
stoic and emotionless as possible but
here we get a scene of him being shocked
and disturbed by the news that he was
killing potential humans this whole time
and we get a weird smile from urlan that
even freaks out Levi which is crazy
after everything Levi's seen Erlin seems
to be excited that they seem to be
getting closer to the truth
despite the deaths of so many people
even though Levi thinks that this is a
pretty big price to pay for just one
step closer
lastly we see the beast Titan himself
people and we get proof that he is in
fact a Titan shifter he has blond hair
and glasses and that's the end what an
ending I mean it really sets up the next
season nicely and makes us even more
curious about the Beast Titan I
personally loved this episode I think
they did an amazing job and I can't wait
for the third season that now we know is
going to be in 2018 people like what a
great day for attacking Titan fans and
all awesome finale plus such amazing
news that no one really expected this is
crazy insane if you did enjoy this video
guys smash that like button and don't
forget to subscribe for more attack on
Titan videos thank you all for watching
and commenting on these videos over the
past few weeks we could not have reached
over 20,000 subscribers so fast without
your insane support guys holy we're
going to have a lot of fun counting down
to season 3 together here on this
channel
as always until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]